good afternoon the corona virus pandemic
continues to grow very sadly overnight
87 more people have died bringing the
total to 422 and our hearts go out to
their families and their friends
yesterday the Prime Minister announced
the most radical steps yet to slow the
spread of this virus and these steps are
not requests they are rules you should
stay at home except to shop for food for
medical reasons for exercise or for work
including caring and volunteering in the
coronavirus national effort we
understand how significant these steps
are we ask for your forbearance but I
think that the public knows that this is
important and they know how vital a task
it is that we get a grip on the spread
of this virus and slow it down the more
we follow the rules
the sooner we will stop the spread and
so everybody has a responsibility to
follow those rules and where possible to
stay at home I know how worried people
are and while this is a great time of
turbulence it is a moment to that the
country can come together in that
national effort as the next step in that
effort today we launch NHS volunteers
we're seeking a quarter of a million
volunteers people in good health to help
the NHS for shopping and to delivery of
medicines and to support those who are
shielded to protect their own health the
NHS volunteer responders is a new scheme
set up so that people can come and help
and to make sure that the NHS
and the local services that are needed
get all the support that they can I can
also announce that the call we made at
the weekend for people to return to the
NHS has been incredibly successful so
far so far 11788 people have answered
that call 2660 doctors over two and a
half thousand other health professionals
and pharmacists and 6147 nurses and i
pay tribute to each and every one of
those who's returning to the NHS at its
hour of need in addition from next week
5,500 final-year medics and 18,700 final
year student nurses will move to the
front line to make sure we have the
people we need in our NHS to respond to
this crisis in total that's over thirty
five thousand more staff coming to the
NHS when the country needs the NHS most
finally I can announce today that we
will next week
open a new hospital a temporary hospital
the NHS Nightingale hospital at the
Excel Centre in London the NHS
Nightingale hospital will comprise two
wards each of two thousand people with
the help of the military and with NHS
clinicians we will make sure that we
have the capacity that we need so that
everyone can get the support they need
but no matter how big we grow the NHS
unless we slow the spread of this virus
then as we've seen those numbers will
continue to rise and that's why it's so
important that everybody follows the
advice and stays at home
the final point I want to make is one of
thanks as health secretary and as a
citizen and on behalf of the whole
country I want to thank the staff of the
IHS those who work in social care all of
you not just the doctors and nurses who
normally get mentioned but the
pharmacists the paramedics the managers
and all staff across the board you are
the frontline in this war against this
virus and we all pay tribute to you
you're going to give you all over the
next few weeks and I want you to know
that we salute you and I will strain
every sinew to get you everything you
need to keep you safe so that you can do
your job keeping all of us safe